Next up some news from another woman who breaks the mold,
the endlessly talented Jenny Slate.
She is one of my favorite people.
And I'm happy to report
that it's time to fire up those tear ducts
because "Marcel The Shell,"
the famous character that she created is getting a movie.
Jenny is bringing the little shell to the big screen,
that she created with Dean Fleischer-Camp
in the Director's seat.
And they created Marcel together a decade ago.
Please take a look at this.
Sometimes I find my mind wandering,
thinking, what would my family think?
(rain trickling)
Do you think they could be out there?
Marcelo, let's forget about being afraid,
just take the adventure.
Okay Lyn, let's do it.
(audience applauding)
Oh my god, he's so sweet.
I cannot wait.
I'm not kidding, I have chills everywhere.
And guess what?
On the phone right now we've got "Marcel The Shell."
(audience applauding)
Hi guys.
Oh it's actually
Jenny Slate.
Hi, it's Jenny.
Hi Jenny.
Oh, I love Jenny.
Hi guys.
Oh Jenny.
I love you so much.
Thank you so much for coming on this show.
I've been texting you night and day.
Is it like true that Marcel might be the closest
to your (indistinct) center?
Yeah, I will say that, you know
Marcel and the way he is
and his easy confidence
and his immediate connection to things
that are really beautiful and important.
Maybe it's not like,
I think it's like closest to what I aspire to be like,
you know to like it's like closest to my best self and,
that's why he's a great character to perform
because I get to step into that mode
and the more I step into it
the more I can replicate it in my own life.
And I think that's just a huge privilege.
Do you think that Marcel could come to the phone?
(laughing)
Oh yeah.
Marcel, you are on the big screen.
What do you hope that people will take away from this movie?
I guess I just want everyone to know that,
it's not only about me because I'm extraordinary,
but because actually everybody has an interesting story
if we just take the time to get know them
and let them be comfortable enough to be themselves.
So, I guess I'm trying be modest also.
(indistinct)
Aw.
(audience applauding)
You're right, Marcel.
You are right.
We are all gonna get into the groove with you
and Jenny Slate.
One of my favorite minds and hearts out there.
I mean, Jenny as a writer I love you,
as an actress I love you,
as a comedian I love you,
and obviously I love "Marcel The Shell With Shoes On,"
comes out in theater's June 24th.
Be aware, get it while it's hot.
And Marcel has had a lot to teach us over the last decade.
And it's definitely a good thing
that he has his own movie,
so that we can all continue
to love and learn from Marcel.
Marcel the movie star.
(upbeat music)